Mark what the hell you passed out drunk
again oh is that with Alec Baldwin we
were drinking doing shots oh that guy
can't stop I don't know he loves a
shooter
all right oh okay I'm a little hungover
I need a drink and a shirt well I got
your shirt with that new Merchant we
might be drunkpod.com all kinds of cool
stuff this shirt this shirt and of
course I got a drink for you oh
beautiful Bodega cat whiskey don't drink
responsibly because we make more money
if you don't yes you got that right keep
driving
[Laughter]
sheath underwear summer's coming and
that means sweaty dick season say I
might be wearing them right now look at
that what's a better promo than that if
you're tired of your dick and stuck in
your balls and your balls getting stuck
to your leg it's sheath underwear two
pouches one for your dong one for your
sack nothing sticks together so you stay
cool and comfortable all summer long oh
I didn't have to look and I'm wearing it
too I got one for your one for your sack
and one for your mistress yeah sheet was
created by US Army soldier Robert Patton
not only did he make an awesome product
but he can support a veteran-owned
company and a podcast at the same time
for our ladies in the audience check out
sheath sports bras bikini briefs and
boys shorts they have tons of cool
patterns yeah Dylan Mulvaney sporting
them it's great
so you can have tons of cool patterns
and ready for any occasion go to
sheathunderwear.com and use promo code
drunk to get 20 off your first order
that's sheets one of money back
guarantee she's underwear.com promo
drunk sheathunderwear.com code drunk for
20 off your first order go to sheath
underwear and let them support your
balls the best the best
foreign
folks we're back we might be drunk and
it's just us ah finally I know these
[__] guess dead weight I call him
yeah dude yeah and Sally speaking of
dead weight salication is here but uh no
it's good uh good to see you buddy hey
good to be back
just us just us we're gonna be alone so
much to talk about yeah you've been on
the road for years yeah you too that's
true you don't have lives no I like it I
like the road me too you know people
like oh the road it must be so hard I'm
like I'm in a hotel room eating ice
cream naked yeah it's great
what the hell am I complaining about I
love the road you can eat ice cream
naked at home ah I got a wife you know
that might turn her off a little or turn
her on but you know you sleep in oh I
got an ice cream rack for you
[__] oh okay so Jenny's no
that's a good one all right Ben and
Jerry's churro flavor whoa cinnamon ice
cream dude it's like 1200 calories per
pint yeah
it's mad good
all right Trey for churros yeah uh
that's a good one dude all right I'm
down yeah I'll tell you I gotta I gotta
you wanna talk sweets I'm eating puffins
daily you read puffins they're good yeah
so good yeah cereal yeah yeah it's so
good Trader Joe's always yes peanut
butter get the peanut butter you'll
you'll jizz I like the yeah I like I
love peanut butter cereal dude I uh I
was in the supermarket hadn't been there
in a while and there's some ice cream
brand I'm in Texas there's some ice
cream brand where all the people on it
are special needs and it took me a
second I was just you know they're all
on the cover and uh and I kind of just
hold one up I was like oh I think
everyone on here is special needs and a
guy walking by without even Brayden goes
yeah and if you eat it you'll turn into
one of them
didn't even break that's pretty good
yeah there's a drive-by zinging yeah I
love those but uh wait why are there
special needs people because they give
money to give special needs people uh
employment it's a good cause it's but
you know I mean the guy's got a point
because you look at the underwear
commercials or the underwear and it's
always a ripped guy you don't turn into
them you don't turn to them I guess
you're right so you're not going to turn
into that guy either yeah Special Needs
so yeah you're fine need howdy yeah it
looked good actually birthday cake
flavor although I love it birthday cake
anything holy [__] oh yeah love that
birthday cake good flavor uh I had a
fudgy the whale last night yeah you ever
had that no is it good it's a it's an
ice cream I know it is I don't think
I've had it no I've never had it either
I'm from the south and it was amazing
blew my mind yeah dude fudgy the whale
there he is look how cute you guys like
ginger ale yeah sure sure not the people
just the food
um
we do like him you know so this was a
local cookies
that's great I have a dick on his nose
oh yeah
gonna puss in his name yeah good for him
that is a dick nose for sure I think
they knew what they were doing yeah so I
was just in Montana speaking of the road
never been it's beautiful out there it's
a [__] to get there but did Bozeman and
Great Falls
um we go to the hot springs that's like
their thing there it's just it's
freezing cold it's mountains but they
have these hot kind of ponds you can sit
in and it's so nice like a hot tub and
uh after you get in the hot springs you
go into the shower and some guy goes I'm
talking to my friend in the shower and
he goes you sound familiar and I go oh
yeah with a naked guy and I'm like Oh I
thought this was some gay code and I was
like oh yeah yeah and he goes I don't
have my glasses on
but you sound like a comedian I know and
he was like doing the squid like the he
had no glasses on and I was like yeah
yeah I'm a comedian and he goes uh yeah
I don't know what your name is but I
like this comedian and we got to talking
he didn't know it was me but he knew my
voice because he couldn't see me that's
crazy so it was like a great moment huh
was it a steam steam room so it's like
cloudy cloudy so he was like you sound I
was talking to my friend Steve room he
was like you sound familiar but I
and I was like oh it's not me it's not
me and I was like faking it and he was
like man you sound just like this
comedian I know and then he goes this
guy marked Norman I go he's good he's
good I'm like blowing myself up and then
eventually I told him better to be
recognized by your voice than your dick
true that's uh no that's crazy man it
happened I was actually the Knicks game
and uh with stav and both having a boat
we got a few times we you know got
stopped but one of the guys grabs me
goes I [__] love you and he puts his
arm around me and takes a picture and he
goes thanks Mark
[Music]
I did it to stop to walk behind he goes
he goes You Man Steve
some of the letters right Steve stuff
has have you ever gotten me I've gotten
you I've gotten you a couple times yeah
I get it like on uh on social media
they're like oh this guy's so funny I
love Sam or whatever I've gotten Mark a
few times it's funny yeah but uh and
also when I do q a I go shout out like a
news story they go say I'm a real I get
YouTube that's a big one yeah what do
you say for me because I never know what
to say I say he's uh he's dying of AIDS
yeah yeah what do you say for me I say a
funny guy big eyebrows because you gotta
say something silly
um I gotta pee for you all right I saw a
guy describe someone recently as just a
straight guy just like a regular you
know white straight guy just goes uh he
goes well this person was a bundle of
joy hmm I was like what are you a
[__] chat bot like it's not how
people speak right that's like it felt
like manufactured yeah it didn't feel
like an authentic thing to me I don't
like bundle of joy because people
usually only use it sarcastically like
it's a real bundle of joy that's how it
should be you yeah it's a ridiculous
calling a person sincerely a bundle of
joy is insane it's insane yeah my P
coach in fourth grade hated me and my
mom came to pick me up one day and he
goes Excuse Me Miss is this your bundle
of joy and she's like yeah and then you
just [__] on me in front of my mom for
like five minutes oh it was brutal and
my Mom hated it but uh that's the only
time I've heard someone refer to me as a
bundle of joy and it wasn't good that's
good yeah he was a dick
how about you got any peeves uh yeah I
got a couple actually because we I
haven't seen you in a while but uh how
about this one
[Music]
I got the guy who said hold on I wrote
These down hold on oh they got a few too
when I don't see you for a while I like
to write them down hold on what do you
got here Sally Sally's got some I gotta
peep some plagiarism a listener called
in here oh hold on a second let me find
it
okay hold on we're all looking at the
screens yeah not good not good I got
another pee for you while we're waiting
all right please I love when a giant
beloved celebrity dies and someone will
write it in in their obituary they go I
hope I'm remembered like this someday
you won't be oh you won't be because if
I outlive you I'm writing one of the
Instagram posts and you ain't Harry
Belafonte [__] Okay yeah how
about you earn it earn it we're not just
gonna talk about you like Harry
Belafonte he's Harry Belafonte it's kind
of like when you get into a crash with
uh you're in the flight of playing with
Kevin Hart it's Kevin Hart died and a
bunch of other people exactly
what do you got hold on I can't find it
Sally play your video okay so I have a
listener uh a viewer called in a a video
peeve here
what am I like you know what my pet pee
my Larry David moment is is when people
are in the passing Lane and they're
going as slow as everyone in the regular
lanes and they block the whole thing and
you can't get around because I like to
um yeah yeah I gotta move and when I
feel trapped I go all Larry David on I'm
I'm thank you for calling in Brad P oh
that peeve stunk that was Brad Pitt all
right well I'm glad to know he's a fan
of the Pod and uh yeah thank God you're
handsome that's uh it is funny to hear
Brad pippy like I'm like I'm like Larry
David
uh you're not really but uh right oh man
Larry David was at the Lakers game the
other day and he's Auntie it's literally
Nicholson Larry David you're just like
two people I'd like to hang out with
very badly but of course but Larry David
the whole game just legs crossed like
just looks grumpy Larry David the entire
time by the way so funny there's so many
of the big Lakers celebrities or Knicks
fans oh really Larry David Sandler
they're Knicks fans baby
they're New York people yeah well I
think Sandler was born in Brooklyn his
dad's his dad is a New York Sports guy
so he's a New York Sports guy so he's
like Knicks Jets Yankees Rangers uh-huh
and Larry David obviously Sheepshead Bay
yeah so there you go
all right hold on I had my pave give us
a peeve I'll tell you we need a beef oh
it was big it's a good one my peeve is
when people don't write down their
peeves I know I know I got a million
notes and I can't sift through well one
is uh I have a guy who always says
exactly he says exactly to everything
yeah but everything can't be exact so
I'll be like uh I was late I got stuck
behind some guy he's like oh exactly and
I'm like no that doesn't make sense to
what I said but he just says exactly
every time so he'll be like you owe me
two bucks and I'll be like ah here's
three is that all right he's like
exactly I'm like that doesn't fit he
says exactly for everything Hitler
killed six million Jews exactly wasn't
six million in one no by the way a lot
of black uh Down syndrome gay and uh
gypsies yeah
I was reading is that uh they did like
they did these uh trials I believe about
for you know like to when you Nuremberg
the D not know the denautification they
did like classes you would have to do
it's not Nuremberg it was like uh so
people like Hugo Boss who manufactured
Nazi uniforms they do like what level
Nazi are you and you get to pay a fine
no he was a low-level Nazi but the fine
was for having slave labor
wait what just guess what pick one yeah
don't be a Nazi and have slaves it's
kind of shitty but uh oh yeah oh that's
wild yeah slave labor and his kids
rebranded so his kids like made Hugo
Boss
you know like 1948 like you know Nazi
light well that was the guys of the work
camps they called more camps they would
have to work to help the German war
engine that was the idea yeah so that
they were slaves do you guys want
employment for no money
sounds like slavery no it's work right
you don't like work it's amazing the
Hugo Boss is still around because you
know some guy shits in the in the ice
cream thing at McDonald's and we're like
all right McDonald's is [__] we gotta
shut it down I guess because Subway's
still going yeah so I guess Jerry wasn't
the founder true well I guess Hugo Boss
wasn't either
if Steve Subway was a child diddler
or Bobby Blimpy Bobby Blimpie but uh no
it's a Puma and Adidas Nazi party people
I know I found out I'm bummed I'm
[__] I like Pumas
Chanel too yeah that's right she blew a
bunch of Nazis apparently yeah I think
she was just a collaborator uh that's
enough yeah collaborate with Nazi do you
want to collab
to a Nazi request damn
why isn't she canceled
she's dead yeah but that doesn't stop
other people that's true we got mad at
John Wayne or whoever this smells
[__] insane is it Ginger cocktail
that's
some grass Ginger Margarita what the
[__] I hope you don't say that when you
got out in your lady
that smells insane
I like to go down and go
[__] is ridiculous
should we collab
say it again what is it lemongrass
Ginger margarita like Thai yeah that is
incredible dude very nice boy you're on
fire today yeah
damn back to the trip right here you go
besides the clap yeah
this is really [__] I'm not a big
Margarita guy admittedly I love how you
make Palomas I like I don't like sweet
cocktails like I like like bitter I like
like as sweet as I get is like a
Manhattan that's kind of sweet as I'll
go but we're in old-fashioned but like
right
I don't like sweet drinks really I drink
like if I drink like non-alco it's like
Seltzer I'm not you know yeah I didn't
open it this way and getting those blue
drinks like those blue Hawaii's and I
was like how old is this opener he was
about 23 and I was like you got to grow
up man
you gotta go up and be a real alcoholic
yeah no I see a blue drink I'm like [__]
that hey it always cracks me up when
you're in a comedy club and they can't
make a proper cocktail but they but
they'll be like we can do a yellow gummy
bear I'm like you can't do a [__]
Negroni I know and the amount of sweet
drinks going out I see the bar lady
making all the it's like espresso
martini with the chocolate but the
espresso martinis not chocolate rainbow
like straight up espresso Martini is
pretty [__] good I've never had one
you don't think there's a good uh oh he
says Mike's not on did we lose all of it
yeah uh
uh muted
I've never had an espresso Martini so
they're pretty good was that all not
usable
just say three ladyboys into the mic and
we'll just use that three other boys
three ladyboys three ladyboys we uh yeah
I was making martinis over the weekend
man just like a fun to just make a fight
show some blue cheese olives in that
[__] if that's what you're into
absolutely do you not like that I don't
like blue cheese balls my martinis what
do you like how about a jalapeno Olive I
love a jalapeno you know what's really
good uh uh pickled banana pepper that's
really good martinis yeah fantastic
interesting but the Bluetooth you do the
banana pepper do you do the banana
pepper uh juice as well a little bit
yeah I'll do a little bit of this that
sounds amazing the only thing for me
with the blue cheese is that like if you
add any like I'll I'll do the like
normal Olive Brine and then put the blue
cheese balls on top because otherwise it
gets like oily which isn't like a good
feel in your mouth yeah and it was just
[__] on banana uh Comedy Club
cocktails but hilarities in Cleveland
used to do a banana pepper Martini that
was outstanding
polarity is like a classy Club you know
it's never heard of that it's a really
good drink and not a lot of people do it
it's very good yeah I like that I like I
mean I was a lot of like at home drinks
I had I had a lot of people try Bodega
cat over the weekend and they and they
loved it hell yeah we're loving Bodega
bottle it's online yeah a lot of uh
old-fashioned Manhattans you know nice
straight up
keep them coming I wish it was
yeah on the shelves in New York well
maybe by now it will be maybe for a
while so praying to God any other peeves
oh I can't remember my people I had a
good one and I I had it today it'll come
to me it was something with the wife the
wife is a peeve Factory
a peeve cave uh
uh I think I've mentioned this before
but she'll two thing women uh like being
called peeves and caves
well she doesn't think well she'll talk
in the other room she'll be like can you
believe blah blah blah and I'm like I'm
in the other room so now this is
[__] you know this too yeah yeah so
then I'm like expect you to hear what
she's saying what what she's like are
you listening to me and I'm like well
you got to come in here and then I end
up going in there for her dumb story and
I'm like you want me to hear this you
coming here so now we're fighting we
have two rooms it's a New York apartment
she's never coming either of those rooms
that's true well uh yeah that's uh
that's it there's something about that
like the talk in the other room like
come here that it is something [__]
annoying about that oh yeah
it's tough it is hilarious when you see
people that have been together for a
long time just fight over [__] that has
nothing to do with that actual like my
parents will do this sometimes we're
like we're driving and my parents were
driving to my sister's place in Brooklyn
and
my parents just it's that thing with my
Dad we got the car and he's like there's
no parking here my mom's like what he
goes there's no parking here and I'm
like I could have maybe just tried it
one more time yeah yeah they might have
been there might be something else that
led in underlying is she preceded this
yeah well one good moment is my lady
will just leave everything open like she
leaves the cupboards open she leaves
she'll go in and get the puffins and
then leave it wide open so they just get
stale so I go hey you gotta close this
they're gonna get stale do you hate me
are you inconsiderate what is it why are
you why can't you just close it she's
like I didn't think about it and I'm
like I know but it's inconsiderate and
so I was like you're that's mean then I
came back later and she had her [__]
open so she does it to her [__] too so I
apologized because I was like oh you're
just out to lunch you're not you're not
doing it despite me you're just doing oh
you thought it was an attack not really
an attack but like hey I ate your [__]
but I I don't respect you so I left it
open oh wow I don't think she would do
that to you I know I know but after
telling her like hey you got to stop
leaving this open all my shit's getting
stale I thought she might stop doing it
but she didn't so I was like oh this is
just you doing it to spite me but she
does to her [__] too so I was like all
right you hate yourself we're good
so that that was a p but I realized she
does it her own stuff
so I felt better
what I got one yeah what do you got
people who pretend to be hurt uh the
victimhood yes remember that kid growing
up he'd be like you were really young
you're playing soccer and you get hit
very lightly but he would go down like
he just got [__] hit by Lawrence
Taylor yeah
yeah because when you're when I'm really
hurt I'm like I'm okay I'm okay that's
when I'm really hurt between you know
I'm really hurt when I'm like a good
point when I when people like fall down
after they get like you know shouldered
by a bicycle yeah like call an ambulance
it's like get the [__] up right good
point when you really hurt you fake it
exactly when you're not hurt you pretend
yeah you think talacuse had to do with
this car he's like oh [__] you you [__]
Jesus Christ oh yeah Stacy my wife she
stubbed her toe on something that I just
left laying around and she was like
really you gotta milk it milking it and
then Matt was like I'll [__] show you
pain Jesus Christ you think that hurts
give Miss Pat in here so she's like uh
and then I'll like I'm sorry you stubbed
your toe you're like this is the most I
can do you know and she was like uh
you're not sorry you just think I'm
playing it up wow yeah yeah I think
playing it up projecting yeah she knew
she was playing it up so she called you
on it so you'd have to deny it yeah but
you have to clean all this Peters no no
no no it's staying in did she listening
all right
they'll be using the trial Syracuse
versus Syracuse yeah I think
I think she's like I'm not listening to
your Pucket I got my own pocket that's
great yeah I've dated women who listen
to me on podcasts and it's like they
just come up with fights which should I
said
and I'm just like oh so now I got to be
cautious I don't want to be cautious on
a podcast right right I'm drunk I have
to be drunk and be like was that a bad
thing to say and we're already worried
about the internet now I gotta worry
about you coming at me shoes you said
something bad in the podcast I was like
yeah I might have been drunk right yes
that's the name of the podcast why we
named it that it's a disclaimer lady
exactly yeah it's uh it's like I have to
fight all of black Twitter and you
it's uh
uh it is a thing like sometimes people
do that where they like listen to your
especially early in the relationship
they want to hear you on pods
stuff like that and you're like oh this
could be a problem Oh I don't think I'm
that bad on no but at the same time
what's the reason yeah
every once in a while every once in a
while you say [__] you're not thinking
you're like hey I'm just trying to be
the intent is always the joke
course you know of course but uh it is
kind of crazy I can't imagine ever
listening to a woman like I'm dating on
a podcast and just being like we need to
talk no I am a little upset with
something you said yeah yeah well I
think I think we're wired differently I
think women are like oh he's on this
podcast I'll listen I'll learn more
about them whereas we're like
I'd like to not learn about you you know
I don't know your stuff and what you've
done Mark's like I was hoping you would
speak less I would never seek out extra
talking I mean this is crazy well I
would rather learn in person and get to
know you let's meet let's hang out
absolutely wrong silent type joke oh
yeah it's an old job I can't remember
the the premise is basically like a
woman is allowed to say I want a strong
silent type but a guy can't be like I
like a woman who talks very little you
know something like shut the [__] up is
what you said yeah there you go shut the
[__] up yeah that's that's the right
punch right there that's good I mean
there's something about uh the Double Do
You Wanna also it's not like I don't get
bothered in relationships I just try to
say like hey this didn't make me feel
good like just be quick and then they
say I think okay I go okay we're good
that's it just don't do it again that's
it yeah why do we need to draw it out
and make a whole fight about it don't do
it again
yeah I mean uh another one is people who
are like this is kind of a peeve where
uh
it's always people who like think
therapy is a sham who I'm like you kind
of need it oh every time you know what I
mean I'm not saying everyone needs it
but it does feel like the people who are
the most just adamantly against it I'm
like you should do it yes you know what
I mean there you get the people they're
like I gave it a shot it didn't work I'm
like I can tell
I can tell it didn't take it's like the
people who in streets say like don't
tell me how to raise my kids they're the
ones that need to know raise your kids
raise them yeah but so true that Miss
Patton here
also why can't I why can't people tell
you how to raise your kids you're
horrible I was watching an old madman
episode where uh one of the kids was
running around recklessly it's like
season one and another dad slaps him in
the face and you think that kid's dad is
gonna be like don't do that but he's
like you see you should behave you were
allowed to hit other people's kids oh
yeah I got hit by other parents I think
that's [__] awesome I think we should
bring that I think stranger should be
alive I think we should be in a flight
hey
[Music]
you know stop that I was like it's very
jarring when you get hit by another
parent because you're like I don't know
how to feel you know when you get hit by
your own mom you're like [__] you Bob
but when you get by someone else's
parent you're like I'm gonna come yeah
it's my first Direction uh
now I need to get my balls dumped on by
a stranger is how it starts how about
those Wall Street guys they love getting
the ball stomped on yeah what is that
like you're you're dominant in real life
and the sub and the sack is that okay
but is that real it must I mean I don't
think I can't say it it's always real my
guess is they're the guys who can pay
for it and so we hear about it well they
get they they're so powerful that they
have to flip it well you think they feel
guilty for all the money they're making
and in the way they're making it and
they're like let me pay someone a stomp
on my nuts a little bit I'll keep making
the money but I do I should get my K my
nuts stomped there's something to that
stomping on everyone else's nuts yes
yeah yeah yes I think it's the same way
like the super trillionaire millionaire
is like this big uh charitable guy
because he kind of feels guilty about
how much money he has so he's like here
let me put a bunch in uh charity it was
like The Wolf of Wall Street guys like I
got my money by we were ripping off a
bunch of people let me have a prostitute
just punch me in the face a few times
you know yeah it's guilt it's probably
guilt and some like subconscious you
know yeah never had that energy I've
never made any money I've never had that
orange either I've made a few bucks but
I've never been like I needed I get
enough [__] all day I don't mind like a
tease like a woman like kind of like a a
hint of insult a little hard to get but
like not like humiliation that to me is
like duh humiliation is like I get
enough of that at work exactly you know
new material I'll just go back to I'll
just go back to Toledo
I was just there and it wasn't pretty oh
my God
City I timed it check spot took 40
minutes 40. 40. my Act was 55. so it's a
15 minute non-check brutal I timed it
were you the funny bone yeah
yeah that one I've had some I've had
some rough ones there oh yeah that's a
Toledo's just not a good place it's a
bummer the good thing is you can call
out how shitty it is you know and how
much it sucks there and they're like we
know we know no I bet like I better be
more fun now but I played a good amount
coming up and I was like man I am
[__] bombing I remember playing a
club there at once and uh it was called
uh laughs Inc
l-a-f-f-s I've heard of this place
didn't last long and uh I was the last
comic ever to perform there yeah you got
the last laughs if you squeeze that
together it's left sink
laugh
why would they make that it's laughs Inc
laughs Inc like laughs Incorporated I
know but if you oh okay I spelled it
wrong there you go so I remember getting
to the airport after this guy drove me
there and I was like oh you know thanks
for having me whatever tough week but
like thanks and they were they were nice
enough and uh
and I I go to the airport my manager at
the time was like did you cash the check
yet and I was like I'm at the airport
what do you mean did I cash the check he
goes cash it immediately and I was like
what he goes they're done so I remember
like texting the guy like dude I'm so
sorry and he goes about what and I was
like I'm not [__] I'm not gonna be
the one to break the news Jesus Christ
whoa I've heard a walk in her room I've
never heard of clothing I closed it holy
[__] I should close that room down wow
last I almost wish we had like some of
the footage from the early days just to
see how we handled some of that [__]
because I mean I I don't want to watch
it but everyone pardon me like the
masochist of me wants to see it a little
bit yeah for sure because you do get
some moments in those rooms because
there you your back is against the cliff
and you're this young Comics you just
pull every sword out of your or out of
every tool out of your tool belt trying
to try to get them over and anything and
it's it's ugly and the beauty of those
rooms though the One Shining Light is
that there's no stakes and there's no
Comics there to judge you so you can
just hack it up [__] with a guy call a
lady a Coos or call that guy a douche
and get away with it yeah it's in the
middle of nowhere oh I remember saying
[__] well I'm like ooh I'd be in trouble
if anyone of anything exactly was in
this room exactly just just going I
remember doing prom shows and like holy
[__] if there's video footage of these
[__] I was saying to these kids like
here you're just like oh boy oh for sure
remember when Tosh got in trouble for
that rape joke and he's like I hope you
get raped right now and I got a big
laugh and it went on the news and he got
in tons of trouble I was like man I said
that on Thursday
Youngstown Mark wasn't even on stage he
said to a woman at the mall I was
talking to a girl scout
I mean it's just really uh you deal with
so many just rude pieces of [__] that of
course you snap of course it's if you
didn't snap that's the person I'm
worried about because they're holding it
in and they're gonna murder a [__]
person at some point yeah yeah Richards
was right let's finish it up yeah yeah I
think he did nothing wrong and now that
was that's not how you handle it
obviously but uh damn was the funniest
cream
so somebody said something to me today
they said uh
kovid killed some cities and I said well
which ones he said San Francisco oh no
come on I was just there it's great it's
great yeah I love it falling apart
getting a lot of bad press a lot of it's
the media dude it's like here's my issue
with it it's like I think a lot of it's
like the media like they want you to
think it's a good story like yeah sure
like California government has been
atrocious but I think a lot of it's a
good people did this with New York New
York's dead it's not [__] dead shut
the [__] up like yeah we got some
problems but every city has problems
every major densely populated city has
problems but you see it with the media
where like the cash app guy gets
murdered oh you see how badly they
wanted it to be a crazy homeless person
totally no guess what no it was some
[__] dude that he knew yeah is that
right some dude's girl and the guy a
sister so that guy killed him before
dating but they really were trying to
Tee It Up Like This I guess this City's
gonna hell a guy got murdered and you're
like I didn't know that no it's yeah
somebody new I I so I and look I think
San Francisco is a great City so I hate
when I hate when that [__] is uh
it's I hate when people like this City's
dead shut up cities go through stretches
you know what I mean like it's it's a
it's a great City yeah well I think the
real test I didn't know that about the
cash app guy that's crazy the real test
is how many people are leaving
I think when people are like really
Exodus on a city that's a sign because a
lot of people a lot of people left New
York I mean there was a mass Exodus for
sure here but you know but guess what
they're coming back new young people
come here and right that's okay some
people you want to move to the suburbs
move to the [__] suburbs it was you
were probably going to move there anyway
you just probably moved there five years
earlier because of coven good point and
the problem with the city with New York
with covet hit New York the city is what
you're paying for you're paying for all
the restaurants and The Nightlife and
the energy and all the people so when
the city shuts down you're like all I
have is this tiny apartment
I don't get the whole city and I'm
paying out of the yin yang for all this
[__] this tiny apartment and the
groceries are expensive so I get why
people look like [__] a girl like
you're dating her but she's got a bad
personality and then she's like no more
sex you're like I gotta get out exactly
that's what it's like great analogy yeah
perfect I'll tell you the sex stopped in
here do we have any good uh emails yeah
we got a few
disregard fake news the news will not
replace us
all right here we go this smells so good
too by the way yeah when you crush up
the lemongrass it just lets out all the
Aromas that's like unreal oh very nice
and the thing is like if you have this
stick you just put it to your nose you
don't smell anything but you crush it up
everything comes out it activates it
yeah that is like one of the best drinks
I've ever had I'm not a margarita
Margarita guy at all it's like when
you're a toilet clogs if you let it sit
the smell will go away but right when
you flush it
it activates it that's exactly how I
like the thing that my life
I clog every toilet on the road so it's
like just after I take a number two I'm
gonna put that on the next menu yeah
thank you poo poo platter you know when
you drop a deuce
that's the highlight all right so um New
York's three one one that's our
non-emergency hotline is there to log
complaints about noises or rats but it's
also uh has been there to field some
bizarre requests like uh can you check
if my boyfriend is married someone asked
that oh I like these transfer me to a
UFO ologist ah and then one caller asked
to be asked to be talked through the
steps of boiling a live chicken while
another wondered if they can claim their
dog on their taxes wow wow the taxes is
not bad yeah it's interesting that's a
good idea because it is a dependent well
it lives with you it's a roommate who's
not paying rent so I guess that is kind
of dependent you feed it you house it
you medical it
you play with it I'm gonna guess that
person was a Jew the chicken potion was
Haitian and it's a new game show
I love junk Sam
what was the other one sorry UFO ologist
all right that guy's a psycho we know
that oh my God and can you check if my
boyfriend is married that one I get yeah
but that's not for 3-1-1 that's like
it's again it's rats that's what you
gotta hire like a pi connect me to yeah
connect me to a PA a pi that's what
that's what like a pi does they're like
they I feel like that's the most Pi jobs
you just like rang that's you know yeah
okay check social media for that this is
what sucks about being a lady is there's
so many Man Lies well I bet a lot of men
have if you are the type of dude do that
you're probably like a private uh true
true
yeah there's so many dudes out there
who because they say women want the top
one percent of guys and so all the other
guys are getting getting nothing so like
the top 10 of men like the successful
tall good looking
uh cool guys are getting all the [__]
so I think a lot of guys have to lie
and a lot of the guys who are already
married who are in the 10 still want to
[__] other chicks
so they have to start a whole new
profile
does that make sense
the other guys aren't getting laid so I
feel like the women are going after the
same guys who are already married
because that guy's in the 10 interesting
yeah see what I'm saying I mean uh
it's one thing to be like this guy I'm
seeing is he married my boyfriend is he
married that's [__] that sucks that's
like okay you're in it and you don't
trust this person at all that [__]
sucks yeah I mean that's like that's
tough can you imagine like how long is
this dude disappearing for
that's what I wanted like he's married
yeah what do you what the [__] are you
doing yeah like what gave what tipped it
off that you're like this guy's married
you know what was the the clue I love
that you're calling 301 like there's too
many rats in the city also does this guy
have a wife yeah do you have another
family yeah if you ask me she's the rat
all right uh a diner divides up divides
opinion okay a diner divides opinion am
I reading this wrong
Diner divides opinion yeah keep going
okay after putting banana on Pizza this
sentence doesn't make sense no that
makes sense Diner divides opinion people
are divided on if that's good or not
probably right yeah Oh I thought it was
a place this is a guy I thought it was a
diner oh okay so it's a single guy a guy
divides opinion after putting banana on
Pizza people have been left miffed at
the fact that the diner person
has put banana on pizza
sparking a debate about whether fruit
actually belongs on it or not all right
people can't decide I'm in the minority
I think pineapple and pepperoni on Pete
if you do it right it can be really good
then we went to this like good place in
L.A we had it delivered to the uh venue
and it was like
pineapple jalapeno pepperoni was [__]
great it was like a specialty pie I
thought I I think pineapple can be good
I know that's like some people think of
faux pas but no the Hawaiian yeah
Hawaiian slice but I like pepperoni
instead of ham oh interesting I'm whippy
on the whole on the pizza but it's I
don't like the pineapple but that's just
me so I'm all for it if other people
like it go for it but I I don't dig it
as long as it's a circle as long as the
pineapple is in like a circle slice and
not the big chunks I think that's the
move but again I've never heard of
bananas weird bananas no good it's weird
when you kind of like are trying to be
an innovator there too
I don't like it it's a part of me I know
it's not but part of me is like are you
just trying to get attention yeah I talk
about these people the way Republicans
talk about trans people I'm like are you
just trying to do you really don't feel
that way what are you doing are you just
a little fake for a little uh Buzz
online
I don't know I think he's getting Buzz
this is a Dylan Mulvaney of pizza this
guy
uh nobody wants banana on a pizza I'm
sorry it sounds pretty gross honestly
yeah imagine biting into a warm cheesy
pizza with a banana on it then getting
some dough and uh tomato sauce with
grease and banana get out of here I'm
not so yeah it sounds pretty gross to me
and every once in a while I'll be I'll
be shocked by Flavor combos like look
I'll give it prosciutto and melon should
not work it's [__] good there are
some combos where you're like okay
that's [__] good but this one sounds
a little you know a little suspect yeah
buying gifts is hard whether you're on
the hunt for a present for Father's Day
or you want to give an unforgettable
wedding gift this plate has you covered
they make high quality metal posters
that can be installed on your walls in
seconds you can literally print anything
on the display make your own custom
piece or check out disc plates
officially licensed designs from Harry
Potter Call of Duty and many more uh
yeah I mean they got back to school they
got some fun [__] in here you've seen
this right I got a taxi driver at home
do you really yeah I love it I can I
love one of one of my favorite movies uh
yeah click the link in the description
to see some of our favorites and get
ready to hang your own piece of art save
20 off 27 off rather if you buy one or
two or 34 off if you buy three or more
the discount will be automatically
applied to your cart when you click our
link use code drunk when you visit
display.com to get the discount that's
displayed.com code drunk or click the
link and are shown in our show notes
[Music]
talking about these guys inflation's on
the rise we're looking for new ways to
save money well one of those ways is
rocket money rocket money is your
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spanning and spit and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place most Americans
think they spend about eighty dollars on
subscriptions a month well the total is
actually closer to 200. Rocket money
quickly and easily finds your
subscriptions and cancels anything you
no longer want Jesus Christ where's this
been all my life I got all these
companies up my ass they're charged me
and I don't even know about it they prey
on my ignorance
so thank you [__] Jeffrey Epstein or
something yes exactly pieces of [__]
yeah [__] you you [__] yeah
yeah I'm still being charged for going
to the island it also helps you manage
your finances by categorizing your
expenses so you can see where your
paycheck is going the average user saves
up to seven hundred and twenty dollars
per year and over three million people
have used rocket money to get a handle
on their budgets stop throwing your
money away cancel on one of
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
drunk that's rocketmoney.com drunk
rocketmoney.com thank you
so we got one here uh woman finds a man
hiding under her bed thinking that the
two felines thinking that the two
felines may have been sleeping under her
bed she reached underneath it only to
find her fingertips
[Music]
terrified the 61 year old woman dialed
9-1-1 wait a minute is he dead oh hold
on okay so developing the man who had
been hiding under her bed crept out and
then fled via the back door
whoa 25 year old Christian vattovic they
got him later apprehended by police near
uh near a canal in the area he was found
in possession of a digital camera and a
gold ankle bracelet wow one of those
fancy prison bracelets damn
that's [__] creepy yeah that sucks
because like I I still like you know
everyone's even just checking to a hotel
and you like open the closet door oh
yeah you're looking at the uh you know
the shower you pull back the shower it
sucks that like now This Woman's gonna
have to do that for the rest of her life
like we really have to do that yeah wow
she's gotta get a boyfriend
he's just a creep yeah it's weird you
assume the worst like he's gonna try to
kill you like thank God that didn't
happen but it's just weird to see a dude
under your bed and he's just like all
right bye and he leaves yeah also forget
the cats get a doberman you gotta have a
dog around now
these cats apparently are just licking
the guy you know while he's under the
bed uh around 80 applicants responded to
an unusual job advert these must all be
English right Peters Europeans okay uh
small advert searching for a cat Chef
the job description stated that the
worker has to take care of the town's
approximately 70 Stray Cats the small
town also erected a cat statue and added
a feline to its emblem to Rebrand itself
as Russia's foremost cat loving
Community okay
well it's the last Direction going up in
that town but
do you need a cat Chef how about uh
Purina Sheba
Meow Mix we don't need a chef especially
for the yeah why are they eating this
well Mill Strays yeah put on a glass of
milk
did I say what did I say man you were
really slipping Services by the way Chef
I'm dyslexic and this is available for
me
we need a non-dyslexic Google [__] what
the hell we should we should have had
that written in our in your job
requirement here okay by the way by the
way I can't read
Jesus uh that's [__] great ketchup
that changes everything all right
all right uh drunk man steals car and
realizes he doesn't know how to drive
damn uh please notice the strange
behavior is this is this about me that's
what I was thinking uh the police
noticed a strange behavior of a man
sitting in a car parked in front of a
cafe when asked to identify himself the
man had no formal documents no driver's
license no registrations for the vehicle
and was that he was sitting in he also
exhibited signs of intoxication
um
well it'd be fun if it was you and then
you're like [__] I'll get on a bike ah
[__]
I'm kind of incompetent
I think Vehicles you're not you're not
going to be I'm not a big vehicle guy so
I said someone tried to zing me like he
he's 36 and doesn't have a driver's
license I've got a license I just can't
drive that's just more about our driving
test in America no I charm my way into
my license there you go I failed twice
and the third time I go please don't
fail me and she's she laughed and I
passed oh really yeah it was terrible
but she was she she found me funny I was
like all right we're in Midtown I was
like uh in the Bronx whoa but I would
say please don't fail me I've already
failed twice and I Gotta Laugh at it
that didn't work with my AIDS test
okay this is our last one thank God High
School how much of this are we actually
keeping I think half
gift code High School sophomore
discovered to be over 30 years old whoa
charity Ann Johnson attended Texas High
School what's going on in Texas for
eight months after enrolling as a 15
year old sophomore damn she must look
good pull her up there we go can we see
what charity and Johnson looks like this
is like a bad 80s movie you know hey I'm
going back to school I gotta learn uh my
squared roots oh there she is yeah she
looks young
not in the right not in the mug shot
Jesus Christ that's she aged a lot from
one to two right there yeah holy [__]
you rarely see people look good in a mug
shot true yeah Gary Busey yeah not a
good James Brown anything in the mug
shots yeah Nick Nolte Nick Nolte that's
what I'm thinking I Gary Busey Nick
Nolte's is rough he's got a Hawaiian
shirt on pull up Nick Nolte's bug shot
if you can oh sorry Sal accuses mug shot
brutal
yeah and he looks rough he's in a
Hawaiian shirt his hair is all out I
hear he's dyslexic yeah
I think he's rather handsome are you
kidding
he was a handsome guy hey he was
look at that he looks like hell the the
crazy hair
Jesus God
look that's the movie as he goes back to
school
I'm a second grade student everyone's
like what second grade [__] Gary
Busey's in second grade
I used to get that mixed up just remake
Billy Madison with Gary Busey it's the
R-rated
you got any [__] you're working on yeah
let's do some bits
hmm
no this on the room oh
gotta put this on my lady's ass yes
it's like a little chili salt
oh you wrote him down on like [__] by
hand I always go hand
I have them too but I put my phone also
I have to email myself
I got some real bad takes some bad ideas
some half-assed Half Baked thoughts yeah
what do you got all right is this
anything yeah
um I was watching the NFL draft you know
fun seeing these young guys you know
their whole dreams are coming true but
wouldn't it suck if the NFL draft was
like the military draft where they just
recruited randos like if your number got
called like Hey sir I know you're five
foot eight 150 pound gamer but you're
playing for the ore you're playing for
the Browns you got drafted I don't know
if that sucks I think that'd be
hilarious well that's how it should work
that would be fun yeah I think that's
how we should do that actually they have
to take one guy that's horrible and play
them yes yes and he's like whoa I can't
I can't play uh you gotta do it for your
car you got a guard Odell Beckham for
one possession yes yes you're on the
Patriots Yeah that's what I've had funny
all right there's a comedian and
something not like that but he was like
to make baseball interesting you know
how you have the ceremonial first pitch
he goes I think that should count I
think you should have Danny DeVito
throwing out the first pitch
hits it for a home run who is that I
don't know oh that's funny though I
think it's uh man you heard a great joke
back in the day Dwayne Perkins had a
joke about making fun in the playoffs uh
the guys always come on like this is all
about who doesn't want to go home and
he's like what's about more than that
yeah you gotta be talented like if you
take the Oakland Raiders and put them up
against a bunch of abused kids those
kids don't want to go home
that's a great joke that's great yes
that's a [__] great bit uh all right
NFL draft all right I'll keep it then
you think there's something there legs
yeah happy happy okay I got something
about an idea about uh like these
bakeries who will make uh wedding cakes
for gay man uh weddings oh yeah I just
think it's like funny to like you spend
your whole life like you're making
sweets and you're just hateful like like
your entire day you're in the back room
with like frosting and sugar and
pastries you're just back there like you
know what [__] piss me off
you know if there's something about that
oh it's one of the gayest occupation in
the world that's what I mean it's like
it's like a very like it should be like
a happy it's like being an anti-semite
and you're just like work in a toy store
or something right it's just weird yeah
yeah definitely I don't know
yeah mate you're making cakes for a
living yeah it's and it's weird to be
like I'm in love with this guy like uh
that's a little too far yeah oh you make
red velvet yeah yeah exactly that's not
natural neither shred velvet yeah yeah
you know what I mean yeah we have
rainbow sprinkles you're right there
you're so close to gay weddings yeah
rainbow sprinkles I hate the rainbow
that's the color of your sprinkles yeah
yeah there you go
[__] the rainbow yeah that's something
there it's all right you're already
packing fudge
there we go okay yeah well they can stop
you from uh they can stop you from
selling it but they can't stop you from
uh deep throating eclair in front of
them
what do you got all right is this
anything so my ladies always giving me
[__] she's like you don't listen you
don't listen and she's right I'm not a
good listener when when she's telling a
story but she doesn't listen during
movies every movie watch is like who's
he again why are they fighting and I'm
like you you know I don't listen to you
but you don't listen during movies and
at least with movies we can pause it I
wish I could pause her and be like hold
on I gotta take a [__] let me rewind
this part's boring I'll fast forward and
then she's like so I uh I got no fight
with my friend at work and I'm like I've
seen this one that's the punchline and
then maybe maybe you should go and you
go [__] this I'll just watch it tomorrow
oh yeah yeah exactly all right yeah I'll
binge
yeah oh yeah you you say oh I binged I
binged the show I would never binge your
stories yes I can't wait for the next
one all right right and I know you have
that Woody Allen joke That's a classic
of a joke about like I was dating a girl
when she came home and she's like uh she
keeps talking I'm trying to watch Annie
Hall and she goes are you ignoring me
during Annie Hall and I was like was
your story nominated for seven Academy
Awards great joke yeah so I didn't want
to get too close to that no I think I
think you're fine but I think yeah the
remote thing whatever binge your story
is there's something like about like uh
oh yeah it's also like I've heard your
stories that's the other thing it's like
I hate reruns yeah that was another joke
I had is about like you know when you
walk in you're like are you passing a
store and you're like uh I love that
Chinese restaurant she goes you've told
me that I was like yeah were you the
only person I hang out with like I spend
all my time with you there's gonna be
reruns I can't I can't bring it every
night you know right so the bit was like
something like uh TV show like Dayton is
like a TV show where the writing gets
progressively worse like season one
you're like this is [__] good and
then season three comes around you're
like we gotta kill off a character
but I think yeah but I think you're I
think that's far I think this bit is far
from both of those okay great
it'd be great to have a remote with a
lady
yeah I'll pause it yeah I'll pause it
I'll pause it check it out later okay
family did that what oh click oh yeah
yeah yeah also can I read the info bar
see if I want to listen to the story
give me the trailer maybe you're like
you got anything on Sports yeah you
should mute it and do the subtitles ah
the mute well that's the problem we're
so used to controlling everything that
we take in and then she's choosing now
oh good boy like you're like [__] I
don't want to hear this so can I do a
different story right now I gotta hear
this one yeah like when a podcast does
ADS you can just skip be nice to do that
with a with a lady
or guy
all right what else you got hey so I
found out I say the word Nazi too much I
say I call people Nazis too much I get
angry and I it was taking me forever to
board uh on Amtrak and I was like
[__] Nazis and I realized if they
were actually Nazis I'd be on the train
by now oh that worked yeah I mean like
that's great look the destination
wouldn't be as good
but we'd get where I was going yeah
that's great
all right there we go I was going to
Auschwitz instead of Columbus yeah I'd
be there they were efficient they were
efficient you got to give them that yeah
efficient people the Nazis yeah no
delays with Nazis I'll let you wouldn't
get your luggage
they just threw all that in a pile yeah
you're like where are my shoes don't ask
yeah you wouldn't get your luggage
I also have to ride with your family
maybe
no seats
but yeah that's true
there's a lot of delays on Amtrak but
also on Amtrak the only difference is
we're trying to get on the train you
know like everybody's like get a
bottleneck going to get on that thing
there was no Cafe car with them
you don't have any Bagels yeah
that's big there's something there that
that bits what else you got stage ready
I think what do you got
um all right so I was playing a video
game the other day which I rarely do and
the lady came home she's really upset
she's crying she's like I got no fight
with my boss at work I hate her she
drives me crazy well what I'm like yeah
I'm fighting with the boss too here and
then uh she's like are you playing a
video game you're so mature you're so
childish and she ripped the cord out of
the the controller out of my hand
I remember being like Oh geez this is
like a whole another video game you know
and I'm like I went from a video game to
an escape room I'm like how do I get out
of this you know you got to beat this
boss to get back to that boss exactly
yes and then the joke or the it keeps
going that part I can't really figure
out and then it keeps going where I'm
like
I am childish I am immature but women
you guys are immature in the bedroom you
like to be spanked you call his daddy we
play with all your toys
and then I thought maybe I could rip the
vibrator out of her hand like that to be
a to be like a tie it all up
I don't know I don't know where to go
with it vibrator's funny yeah
so I got the toys I got the spank I got
the the daddy those are all immature
that's their vibrating controllers yeah
yeah they're like uh
her uh
there's something funny about like how
both our toys vibrate yeah true
I don't know something about uh it's
kind of two different bits that I'm
trying to connect right
fighting with her because the original
joke was
you're gonna you're gonna call me
childish while you're crying that's
pretty pretty bold and I thought well
that's then she shits her pants
yeah I don't know it's a tough one I
can't crack it
yeah it was two different beds yeah
because the first one is about like you
know but I think they're connected right
yeah because they're both a mature thing
I'm playing a video game she's getting
spanked she's calling me Daddy she's
using toys she's mad at you for
you're ignoring it for the video game
yeah she's ignoring me with the vibrator
difference is you you maybe the joke is
when you play with the vibrator when you
want to play it's kind of like when she
wants to play video games you're like
all right but you're not that good at it
oh that's interesting yeah I mean yeah
maybe I invite her to play the video
game with me
you're just hitting the same button
she's like well that's what you're doing
with the vibrator yeah that's not bad I
don't know
well do you know how like when you're
getting hit by a boss in a video game
your controller vibrates that's supposed
to be like a bad thing right but when
her vibrator vibrates that's a good
thing right so you just like tie those
two ways together so you're getting
killed over here but I'm living over
here right right yeah do people know
about that the vibrator vibrating
okay okay
all right all right I'll try to connect
them with the controller yeah
um I had one about uh like you ever
dating a new person and uh it makes you
realize that you're past 17
relationships are all toxic because
she's actually like nice to you like uh
like it's just too real like she woke up
she woke up from a nightmare and I was
like I am so sorry and she was like why
are you sorry it's not your fault and I
was like oh my God
it's not my fault
yeah there's something about like it
just puts in perspective you know what I
mean everything yeah maybe it's like
you've worked in all these horrible jobs
and you finally have benefits yeah and
you're like can I get all yeah you have
eight days of vacation time you're like
what you know some comparing it to
something where you're like wow this is
crazy it's so much easier
like maybe you lived in a in a Work Camp
your whole life in uh Russia and then
you gotta get to America you're like hey
yes
I think it needs an analogy probably
well maybe it's when you move out you
know it's like you live with your
parents so they're just busting your ass
all day yelling at you making you do
chores and you're like move out and live
with eight guys and you're like wow we
can eat cake in the morning
yeah there's something I don't [__]
what do you got uh that's up there
uh you've been beating your whole life
uh hold on all right all right is this
anything
I'm so annoyed how addicted to my phone
I am I'm so addicted to my phone and I
think it's two things are [__] young
people up is phones and adderall and
they're actually quite similar they're
addictive they keep you up at night and
our parents gave them to us so we'd stop
annoying them you know and then I'm like
uh
the phone and when you run out of
Adderall or you your phone dies you act
the same way you're like I gotta call my
provider you know I gotta get hooked up
I need another line
another line like phone line is I don't
know if it reads it might people do
snort Adderall I never did that [__] but
I never did it yeah I could change the
coke
you know you could say uh hey it's
addiction I think why it might work does
it hit I haven't tried it but I'm
worried phone line almost sounds like a
landline because no one talks about a
phone line yeah wait so say that the
last part again uh when you run out of
Adderall or when you your phone dies or
you know let's say you flush it down the
toilet both of them you're like I gotta
call my provider I gotta get hooked up I
gotta pay some money gotta get a new
line
I get I gotta get a new hook up yeah I
gotta get a new yeah um
yeah that's 5G
uh
five grams
there's some guy out here who's like you
need the 5G 4G LTE I guess oh yeah yeah
right bite in Chinatown by a knockoff
you can't trade in your old Coke for a
better cook
yeah yeah you can't be like this is uh
this is bad code can I get good Coke
yeah this is a Samsung yeah yeah
the tough one
I love a good comparison joke these two
things are alike and you start drawing
about throwing out examples of how
they're alike
yeah
um
a lot of dead air on this one no no no
we're thinking that's fine it's uh
the bone and Adderall you need a
subscription or with a phone you need a
prescription with a phone you need a
account what do you call it when you get
a phone there's no family plan for Coke
oh there is for Adderall well your
parents buy it for you yeah
kind of have to go through your mom to
get it
on both accounts the government is
listening aha
yeah
phone keeps you up at night it connects
you with people Adderall you're making
connections you're dealing you really
want to start a business with both
you drop either in the toilet you're
like [__] my life yeah yeah Coke or
phone maybe I don't know there's like
right
see there's there's a lot of examples
here yeah
screen time maybe there's a way to
connect them when you use Adderall you
look at your phone too much yeah [__]
AI Adderall intake oh boy
all right
[Applause]
um let me try another I got it with
another is this funny at all like I want
to do a thing about jump writing folks
is General does this generation even
know what what wedgies are or something
I wrote like I feel like the The
Bullying is so different like now it's
all like you used to get your underwear
ripped up your [__] and it's like it
was a simpler time now what do you do
you like ruin someone's life over the
Internet yeah so I think the angle is
like it just doesn't have the Personal
Touch uh you know what I mean yeah like
we were like goons back in the day and
these kids are like International Super
Villains right we're like we just like
ruined your underwear these kids are
like what's your social security number
oh yeah something like that I don't know
yeah back then we swirl you now and
steal your identity
there's something to that right yeah
yeah for sure back then it took a little
sweat he had to burn some calories to
[__] with a guy
swirly wedgie uh dunk them in the toilet
uh
he hung their shorts up on the flagpole
there's a little effort a little effort
but it was also just like not nearly as
bad no no no no no no no I might come
home you might I it is an older bit I
used to have about like how like back in
the day they would like beat the [__]
out of you but now it's like
like you get catfished yeah it's like
you know you would like get a black eye
back in the day but now you like take a
Greyhound to Syracuse and you're like I
thought you'd be a woman yeah
yeah you know that could be a funny joke
back in my day got Wet Willie now you
get catfished yeah it kind of sounds
similar but yeah that was an older bit
[__] camping that this is big jokes are
[__] hard they're so hard but this is
good yeah it was so uh micro and now
it's like a macro like we ruin your life
we take your credit card account we take
your Social Security we get your
identity oh my God how many texts do you
get now where it's like this is UPS and
like no it ain't yes exactly this is a
Nigerian prince
you got anything else it was very analog
back then like a wedgie is very Hands-On
yeah versus uh
uh you know scamming old people
all right this is horrible what do we
have anything else uh I got a bit for
you please
people always say if you have sex with
your clone is that gay but nobody ever
asks is a pedophilia because clones have
to start as babies and raise them up
when I was 12 and masturbate I didn't
get arrested for it touching the 12 year
old but if I helped turn off my clone is
that how to kill you interested [__]
I mean this is a complex bit here man
yeah very complex we talk about like
going back and killing Baby Hitler we
never go back to [__] ourselves this
sci-fi novel here
um yeah is it pedophile well I guess it
depends at what age it's also incest did
you groom yourself now you got
pedophilia incest and cloning and gay
yeah there's a lot of uh boxes we're
checking here I think we hit most of
Reddit yeah
oh man I think I think that's cool
I was gonna say I think it's really cool
Mark normally says thumbs up [__]
yourself is fine
you know it's kind of like how you can
make a joke about yourself like you
can't make a joke about black people
because you're like hey you're not black
that's weird but if you make it you [__]
yourself it's okay
let me try another one all right I was
talking to a guy and he goes he just
goes you know wasted potential is the
worst thing in the world and I'm like oh
it's pretty bad and he was like you know
this is a weird example but Hitler you
know and I was like uh-huh that is a
weird example it's a weird one he goes
you know could have been uh much bigger
you know could have been much bigger
made a few wrong choices and I was like
yeah man I don't know if that's wasted
like I I don't like Hitler I wouldn't
call him an underachiever I feel like he
did his damage it's also weird to be
like you know you know who wasted like I
think wasted Talent I'm not like you
know what comes to mind is uh is Lindsay
Lohan and uh and Hitler yeah both should
have both should have had a bigger
impact yes he should have yeah he should
have maybe made a few different
decisions maybe in Dunkirk and uh she
should have tried to wait to find a way
to sign on for Mean Girls too I don't
know right hey right he could have uh
taken a few vacations you know he did
he's literally the poster guy for are
doing too much six million Jews is a
good number right he killed someone
called a good number well you know what
I mean it's a uh it's a hiding not a
very upsetting number actually
it's a big number I think there's like
Louis CK but he's like he killed a few
too many Jews yeah yeah
no that's great it's so true it's a
weird choice but he was uh he achieved a
lot you know you can't deny that but
yeah a home and overachiever yeah yeah
he definitely achieved too much
yeah yeah he did a lot I mean the the
the the
camps the trains the rounding up the not
to mention it in what's that the
invading invading the manufacturing he
made all these planes and great painter
too yeah solid painter I'd say it's one
of my favorite yeah I'm a big Francis
Bacon and Hitler man those are my two uh
he's an artist
a man's an artist
uh no that's big
yeah all right this is this is horrible
all right what do you got all right so
but I was thinking back to my single
days and how hard it was to like meet a
lady you know like go up to a woman and
a hit on her just cold I remember you're
doing pretty damn well well I I learned
the the ropes a little but it it was a
lot of it was that's why I equate it to
hooking up with a woman you don't know
is like trying to get through TSA
without a ticket you know you had to
like go hey I'm a good guy you know you
have to be Charming you have to work
your way through but once you've already
hooked up with a girl that was like
pre-check she's like oh yeah you're good
come on in but once you get married then
you're part of the flight crew she's
like you again you're here I don't even
know you were here today or whatever I
need a good
marriage one it's funny too that like
except you're the one trying to Pat them
down oh yeah but uh yeah you're you're
in you're in when your ticket yeah no
ticket is single they're like why would
I let you in I know nothing about you
yes exactly exactly I need to vet you a
little yeah but once you're in you got
pre-check come on in you know you don't
have to get dressed you're trying to get
your stuff in here right right
the marriage is
clear uh no one knows what clear is what
about marriage is like the pilot trying
to get the gate
of the plane into the gate
oh like like talking to the control
tower
the pilot versus the control tower yeah
but now we know they still won't
right right they still won't let him in
oh that's not bad
because he's like we gotta wait we gotta
wait till like every time right yeah
we're gonna taxi a while yeah so now I'm
like the horn the horny husband who's
like I'm waiting for you to be ready oh
that's interesting we flew in a little
early even though the control Tire
wasn't letting us because of uh overcast
Sky yeah yeah there's some red clouds on
the horizon
security behind the family going to
Disney World with all their bags it's
gonna take forever
there's something about there's
something about
um not letting you in I need to make
sure that you're not dangerous like yes
treat you like a terrorist I think yes
like the word dangerous I think
resonates for both right because women
are like I can't go home with you I
don't even know you're could be a
murderer yeah which you had to go I'm
not a murderer I'm a good you know
here's here's my ID trust me I'm
supposed to be on this plane you know
like I think uh
I think you're gonna want me to get
through security
but then when you once you've already
had sex with them then it's you're in
then you're stamped pre-check then
you're like you up and they're like come
on over
and that's one of pat down actually
makes a difference like all right what
are you carrying here huh right you have
enough yeah
um but the marriage thing that's where
I'm struggling it's like that's not bad
control tower is not bad like the vagina
is a control tower you think about like
the movie Airplane like that was the
whole thing like yeah
that was a great movie that was like a
running that's my favorite Hangover
movie oh really every time like yeah
absolutely so good Dad and Grandma's Boy
all right love Grandma's Boy uh I got
one I have a whole Chunk on like
companies
uh
uh you know trying to let you know their
opinions on thing I kind of make fun of
Netflix and HBO like trying to be like
allies and I have a bit about you know
Bud Light and now I'm I'm working on a
bit like you know basically saying like
years ago Chick-fil-A made this mistake
known as they were anti
gay marriage which is like you know you
make chicken no one gives a [__] no like
if you have poultry opinions great but
like no one gives a [__] that's like if
you if you want to tell us you're bad if
you want to tell us your [__] up
social commentary at least work it in
the ad you know what I mean like uh we
at Chick-fil-A were against a woman's
right to choose unless it's a uh unless
you choose the morning uh chicken
biscuit breakfast sandwich
you know what I'm going for here sure
sure I'm flubbing the delivery here but
it's something there I think wait wait
you're saying if you're gonna have like
a controversial opinion yeah at least
working out of the ad somehow so it's
not just out of nowhere you're just like
shocking us uh like why are you telling
us you ain't that gay man has nothing to
do with your product Oh interesting
but if they work it in the ad they won't
sell I know but at least then it like
makes sense it makes no sense why you're
just telling people
you know you don't like gay people
getting married it's kind of like why
did you even say that you're a chicken
place
yes you sell chicken yeah tell me about
your sides or something or your [__]
you know lemonade I don't know oh at
least make it uh at least make it
relevant right oh that's funny yeah make
it relevant like put it into the the
pitch right right yeah but you got to
put in the pitch where it's still the
food is still sellable exactly yeah all
right we're against gay marriage but
we're not against the meeting of chicken
and Polynesian sauce or something yeah
uh is that Paul is that the Polynesian
sauce place oh yeah yeah honey mustard
they got barbecue I've never eaten there
before in my life oh it's a little
butter or Prussian potatoes it is good
that homophobia really adds to the
flavor we put the home in homophobia
yeah there we go
cooking homo cooking yeah
I like putting that in the ad
and then you could do that for the the
cake you could yeah I'm trying to
connect all this [__] yeah yeah the cake
is like uh see us on the road folks and
it all it all come together
we don't approve of uh laying down with
another man but we do approve of laying
down seven layers of icing or something
right right all right well
this is all [__] right here should we
wrap it up I think so well I'm buzzed
we've been drinking all day this is
probably
too much alcohol in our lives
can you get that out of that box right
there oh we got boxes that Banner we
want a contest
wow a YouTube channel joke world did a
March Madness oh and we won is that
right yeah I don't even know what that
is how does that work they put a bunch
of different podcasts comedy podcasts
against each other and we came out on
top
who would we beat out last round was
Chrissy chaos oh my God
suck it Christy an honor to be against
our good friend Krista Stefano and also
suck our penis Chris yeah blow me with
your weird glasses
thank you that's a great uh YouTube
channel joke World check it out and what
is this dick fuel oh they they give me
t-shirts
the guy makes zines
not magazines zines he took the Maga had
a magazine oh we got a card here open
bar free food need we say more save the
date we're tying the knot dear Sam and
Mark we know Atlanta's a long way from
NY but we wanted to tell y'all
we're saving a seat and a paper plane in
honor of our favorite comedians pod
thanks for putting on some of the best
shows we've ever seen cheers Colin and
Alex hey Mazel Tov very much how cute
that's a hot couple send us photos of
you guys making out
hold on
in a minute do they send us this oh okay
this is different what's that
there you go
Sam and Mark we got a little card here
oh Nelly what do we got here it says uh
well this is a long thing but Sam and
Mark I caught your Neil Brennan app
where you guys all said you don't feel
sexy I know this is a podcast by
comedians with other Comedians and a few
randos so I Am 98 certain you were all
joking but in case here's a reminder to
feel and think of yourselves as sexy
seriously in general sure seriously and
genuinely I am fat as [__] all right
sexy [__] uh I'm a fattest [__] brown
girl not lizzo another one can feel sexy
and relate to DJ khaled's song for free
then you two can feel it too I had sorry
the handwriting is a little jumbled I
had these small tokens with an
affirmation made for you to always
remind you of your sexiness well it
ain't gonna work but I appreciate it for
free the song where Drake ruminates on
his own sexual prowess by the time he
reaches the chorus he realizes he's so
good at sex that he should be
compensated well I will never feel that
way
but thanks wow what a nice lady read
that
that Gary can't join you on the road
trigger warning corny cheesy encouraging
messages feel free to toss in the trash
every time what is it did I fart in this
card maybe whoa a gift card Mark you see
me get uncomfortable and complimented
and praise so I will try to keep this
short and emotionless as possible oh God
I can't read this this is gonna be sappy
and gay
you opened it so check it out it's this
gets worse free shirts are awesome and
stolen shirts are thrilling to you but
you also deserve to choose one and buy a
shirt for no other reason than you feel
and look good in it please treat
yourself to a shirt that makes you feel
worth it
be it a leopard print silk button-up
shirt or plain well-fitting shirt
whatever you get get something that you
love but would normally talk yourself
out of because of Lost
because of cost or because you already
have enough shirts PS per Chrysler seems
passionate about it James purse t-shirts
or maybe he's just sponsored by them all
right fancy shirts are they yeah well uh
we love that guys thank you so much for
listening I got a Walgreens gift card I
see here what is yours uh Visa oh yeah
no mine's too but I think it says
Walgreens oh yeah yeah I guess they
bought it at Walgreens thank you this is
too much money whoever that was stupid
thank you so much we love you and uh
should we plug some dates or something
here
uh when does this come out Matt
we are backlogging like [__]
all right well you can see me in
Portland Maine uh [__] oh good city oh I
love it Hampton Beach New Hampshire
mashing Target Connecticut
uh Richmond Virginia Greensboro North
Carolina Asheville Charlotte Knoxville
Memphis
Birmingham Chattanooga Nashville Denver
uh Santa Fe San Antonio Houston way more
so many dates coming up they're on
samurai.com yeah we just we got Columbus
on there we had to reschedule that in
Cincinnati Bethlehem York all that [__]
but it's all my website now see you
there hell yeah I'm all over the road
I'll see you in Australia I'll see you
in uh Austin Toronto well you name it
uh check out the website that I'm
announcing a theater tour it should be
already out by the time this comes out
so check my website check the
tabloids you name it thank you Netflix
special coming out soon and uh we'll see
you all at hell thanks a lot praise
[Music]
close
to get down in the same way
[Music]
s
come on
be true
[Music]